good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast brought to you by
better help it doesn't matter who you
are or what you have life can be pretty
damn hard and without a healthy mind
it's even harder check out online
therapy with betterhelp.com
toast and be on your way to a little
more ease good morning jackie how are
you good morning claude you know i've
been better if i had to categorize this
day
i would say it's turning into a
cleveland day jackie
i i hear you
i know you've been through a lot this
morning with the president being in town
and the like is the president in town
it's the u.n general assembly oh this
week probably both if i had to guess
right i think one precludes the other
therefore like the city turns into a hot
mess gridlock can't get anywhere streets
closed down
but
i implore you to have a different
perspective on the matter if i may okay
i'm listening it's monday
we're rising we're grinding we're
hustling this is our week we're gonna be
successful make changes be happy
come on it's a monday
what's wrong with you i don't know did
something happen yeah i tripped and fell
on my head you're living in a parallel
universe you're like a positive person
no come on it's monday where you're like
of someone who posts inspiration quotes
we're rising and grinding are you not
i this morning you know what i was this
was like the first time in a few weeks
that my hair is done because i've had no
energy the last two weeks to do it but
we had um our friend kristen's bridal
shower yesterday so my hair i did it
yesterday and i was excited to like come
here you know
here's my hair it's so long needles
um and i'm wearing some new maternity
clothes my shirt and my pants are both
from asos maternity oh did you enjoy the
journey of asos maternity i did i also
tried on the dress this morning that
just it tr it tried me okay
i understand it did and still i kept my
upbeat out did you return the dress or
you're gonna no because
no i'm not returning you never know and
also maybe if it was shortened it would
be cuter but if i wore that to the toes
like you would take me for evaluation
you would say something happened to her
yeah okay so let's check on the baby
the pants and my and top are from asos
maternity so i'm feeling comfortable and
then my sweater and my shoes are from
joshua sanders which was um the shoes
too the shoes too what is this company
i'm okay i'm skinning you i you are
gonna you they sent you that sweatshirt
you're getting me one and i want the
shoes okay okay but remember that time i
got those pink boots that were like um
sort of like
what's the word like timberlands but
like they were packed of course of
course okay that brand is joshua sanders
and i was so excited about the boots i
posted them on my story and then like
they reached out and so when i announced
my pregnancy they were like we want to
send you a few things oh that is so
sweet sending tings they sent tanks so i
got to like pick out a few things that i
wanted including these shoes and this
sweater which i love so much maybe i'll
just place an order and stop like
waiting for free things like i'll just
place an order well i was going to let
you borrow this sweater because i do
think you would really like it
and it's so you like it has the smileys
on no i'm telling you you didn't hear
from me because i'm not really much of a
fashion expert but like cardigans are a
thing like they are officially thing and
i have one how many times can i wear
this taylor swift march like i need real
cardigans and you catch mirror you do so
uh we'll get we'll we'll hook you up
thank you so so much how was your
weekend
my weekend was good it was actually
pretty good you know a lot of time spent
with brew so important a little it was
productive for me considering i am the
laziest [ __ ] alive these days like i
got a manicure that's nice
and we had the bridal shower and i did
my hair i'm telling you like it is
overdrive last week alone i had two
bridal showers and a bachelorette party
like we're doing double duty we're doing
double duty and it's like the last licks
of nice weather in new york so like so
much shit's coming up like weddings
bridal showers so it is
a full-time job having so many friends
and being as popular as i am i know i
feel like nobody
was as busy or popular as the snitch
have you been following her
yeah what do you mean she's just like
out every night
gorgeous she's really being like an
influencer i know i'm i feel so proud
like a proud big sister i saw her just
like you know hanging out with other
influencers on her instagram and i'm
like you go it counts you influence and
then like other influencers i follow
like my little sister was coming up on
their stories as i was just like
cruising around i'm like go counts go
count she's so influential well honestly
i had such a balanced weekend because i
spent friday night doing absolutely
nothing watching so much downton abbey
being so at peace with myself and then
on saturday night i hit the town horde i
went to like i guess you could call it a
concert
kind of
yeah emo night yeah it's a club night
it's not a concert well webster hall is
not a club
yes it is no it's a concert venue
you couldn't just hit the clubs at
webster hall no it's like not a thing
well it's also five floors so like
doesn't something different happen on
every floor it's in
that's what i've heard well whatever i
had the best time it was emo night you
know like aaron gilfoy from the vlog
squad her fiance
runs these events it's called the imo
night la and they do them all over the
country and they had ben
dj there's like a 30 minute guest spot
dj after carly and aaron d jade and ben
like put together a playlist and
honestly thank god for erin because like
ben did not know how to work the
technology at all um it was
so fun it's like emo music so you know
like simple plan like the usual 90s
semi-charmed kind of life fall out boy
which is ben's like favorite type of
music and honestly it's like one of my
top
genres it was so fun like if you have a
local emo night i encourage you highly
to do it it looked really fun it was so
[ __ ] fun i'm glad you guys had a good
time and then i watched so much downton
abbey and honestly like i'm obsessed
like every minute i'm not in my bed
being transported to downton i is a
minute wasted of my life i agree by the
way how does theo feel about downton
does he love it because brew loved it no
he doesn't have a particular like
connection to it at all they're hunting
and the dogs
they very rarely hunt when we finished
downton bru was inconsolable so i'm like
nervous i'm like at the end of season
three that means i'm about to be at four
and there's only six like i'm really
like i need to slow down the thing of
the movie i know and then you have the
next movie coming out this christmas
that you have to look forward to so i
feel like that's a lot to look forward
to i don't want to spoil anything so if
like you're thinking about watching it
just like put this on pause really
quickly but i'm about to say something
that happened okay we'll give you a
signal when she's done
oh my god like lady sybil dead death
just childbirth over that was so
shocking i mean honestly like i think
the key to a good show was like killing
off main characters and if somebody had
to go like it was going to be civil like
she didn't even live at downton she was
in ireland and honestly they were like
so rebellious they were starting to
annoy me like everything had to be like
a problem you know like they couldn't
live in england they had to go to
ireland they didn't want to work he had
to work in a garage you know he couldn't
be catholic they had to it couldn't be
christian had to be catholic like
everything was like a [ __ ] problem
with them and honestly like as much as i
wanted sible to be her own woman like
you have to respect your family and she
did not respect her family honestly at
all i i agree i mean
you're in for
for so much what did she come back for
the dead no no no no but like but they
just offered tom a job yeah which i want
him to stay like
what is he gonna what is he gonna do in
liverpool with nobody like
your hope everyone's there they love you
and they're really and they have the
baby now right and everybody everyone is
like growing
tom is growing on everyone like the only
one who really still like doesn't like
him is the dad who by the way i kind of
take back every good thing i said about
he's such a loser like he is no like
he's turning into one of my least
favorite characters like his
refusal to modernize like in any
capacity is so frustrating and i guess
like the dowager countess also has that
kind of mentality but when she does it
it's funny she's fabulous fabulous and
you know what and she knows when she
like can you know give a little give a
little he's so [ __ ] stubborn like
even matthew when it's like he's just
stubborn for stubborn sake like whereas
the dowager is principled no okay so
like he was absolutely kerfuffled
devastated when he lost his money and
now matthew invested in downton because
he got the fortune from lavinia's family
and he's looking at the paperwork and
he's like this is the most poorly run
estate in the country like no wonder why
we have to be saved every once a
generation like i just saved you and
honestly if we can fix things up like we
could be a self-sufficient estate until
the end of time which is such a
reasonable thing to say and like
literally the dad was so devastated when
he lost his money now that like matthew
saved him he wants nothing to change
even though matthew's like literally
pointing out if we do this we can make x
like it's so simple he's so [ __ ]
stubborn he's not even he's saying no
just because it wasn't his idea and he
feel like he's being pushed out but it's
like you know what maybe you should be
pushed out oh also mr bates got out of
prison thank god that whole story line
was honestly too dragged out that was a
dark time no and honestly for a while
i'm like let him run in prison like i
just couldn't have cared less anymore
like and they dragged it out
such drama the two of them oh and then
thomas just got caught trying to kiss
that new boy uh james who's not gay and
o'brien like set the whole thing up and
i hate
thomas but when he got in trouble with
mr carson like i actually felt bad for
him like that's how bad miss o'brien
like [ __ ] him over and have you has
that chapter closed on no it doesn't
happen mr carson like just found out
okay and it's like hella homophobic it's
like crazy that it was only like a
hundred years actually a hundred years
is a long time but it's just still like
crazy like the [ __ ] you people used to
say really crazy
keep watching
first but i do want to tell you three
words
you are fired no no you you will never
guess them but there's three words that
just change the really oh my god i need
to get out of here like i have to go
have such a busy day first we're
podcasting with a guest later then i'm
expanding my journey to seeing the snow
by christmas i'm seeing that apartment i
sent you last night i'm i'm not i'm not
optimistic at all i'm more optimistic
about this one than the one that you saw
on friday so update for the one that i
saw on friday it was nothing of the sort
okay jackie hated it and like i didn't
really love it but every person i've
been showing it to and like telling them
the location they're like you have to
get it like i'm telling you it's
probably already on and they got like a
thousand dollars over asking like your
friends don't want you to be happy i'm
sorry like i just i know you so well the
thing is i'm sure like sure that
location is great but you also
need home you need like yeah so while
the apartment wasn't ideal there were a
few things that did stand out one the
realtor told me dakota johnson nope
dakota fanning used to live in that
apartment the one that i actually saw
and that was exciting then he also told
me that he's not sure if he still lives
there but john mayer lived here live
told us that live in the building and
that was a real exciting journey but you
know what i couldn't tell like the
apartment wasn't perfect for me but the
two girls who lived there and i'm so
sorry to put them on blast like they
were
slobs i couldn't believe like how people
were living and they had pictures of
themselves what is that is there a man
behind you no
um there was like pictures of themselves
everywhere and i'm like these are
literally gorgeous girls like
tidy up you have company and maybe i
didn't like the apartment because it was
a pigsty i had no i because i'm not even
thinking of their style i'm thinking of
the floor plan it was just nothing of
the story it's a downgrade from your
apartment now like you i don't know what
you're doing obviously
i'm you're just like there's such low
inventory like i have lowered my bar
significantly but you can't lower your
bar below your current apartment
yeah i agree with that right like what's
the point
i guess because i'm moving to like a
different area yeah like prices vary per
area yeah i don't know i'm seeing
another one today i don't have high
hopes but i do like the area but like
honestly this apartment appears to be
nothing of the sort but like i have to
start actively looking i have to start
manifesting like
that yeah okay well good luck to you
thank you i'll be here along the way you
know giving you my honest feedback
you're welcome to come as i always do i
will come when i think it's the one okay
thank you i appreciate that yeah of
course because i can't make a decision
that's a long car ride for a pregnant
lady no i will not subject you to any
torture until the timing is right thank
you very much
um as for me i watched a show called
wolf hall on friday and saturday it was
only six episodes um it's about henry
viii and like thomas cromwell
star-studded of course claire foy damien
lewis you know all the people game of it
was like a mixture of game of thrones in
the crown speaking of game of thrones
literally sir richard carlisle being
jorah from game of thrones
remember how mario was almost married
that yeah no you'll start to notice that
the same folks start to show up yeah
there's like a british acting crew that
like all act in the same [ __ ] yes and if
downton like sparks a historical journey
for you you'll see your old friends
around delightful yeah and then i
started last night outlander
oh yeah because everybody tells me to
watch it because it's like historical oh
is it yeah and it's like a bit of time
travel
um
and i'm three episodes in everyone said
well someone said to me that the first
two episodes are like so slow if you get
through them you'll love the show and i
agree they were slow but like i'm into
it then someone else said only the first
four episodes are good and then the rest
will traumatize you
there's like five seasons that's crazy
so
i'm just gonna you know take it at my
own pace but i'm really enjoying it and
it's nice to have like i have a show to
look forward to every single day i'm
probably never gonna read again because
i'm just watching outlander no i'm done
with my kindle like downton abbey is the
only thing i need ever for the rest of
my life like it's so [ __ ] good i wish
there was ten seasons i could watch even
like the most boring [ __ ] like you know
nonsensical drama you think that and
then you'll watch the movie oh
and you'll say you know what enough is
enough yeah that's that's a fair point
yeah but it's good it makes you like
want to be done with it yeah well we
have a great show because not only is it
you know monday five fast side stories
the emmys were on last night lots to
discuss but also real housewives of salt
lake city and potomac were on last night
so we have a big fat juicy tv recap for
you at the end of the episode so stay
tuned for that and if that's all i think
i am personally ready to put my swimming
cap on and dive in
i agree oh i guess this is an alert that
the downton spoiler is over
oh yeah downton spoilers over good luck
guys yeah
okay without further ado
where are you
not here today cause we have guests
gorgeous literally
gorgeous thank you it is time for the
past life stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
halo caller speaking of do that
you know
how important our baby doggies theo and
bruno are in our family and that's why
when it comes to keeping them safe happy
and secure we knew the halo collar was
the only collar we would ever use halo
is the only smart system with a collar
that trains tracks and protects your dog
so they can safely run free you set up
halo fences by walking the perimeter
with your collar or at the touch of your
finger in the halo app you could train
them with natural simple profound
communication via the custom feedback
you set for your dog it can even include
your voice you stay connected to your
dog and see how they're doing from
activity to safety status and the gps
works without cell or wi-fi and you can
create up to 20 fences instantly check
out their 90 second video on the
shophalo.com
sorry shop halocolor.com
toast again that's shop halo caller
h-a-l-o-c-o
dot com slash toast and you can take
advantage of the special limited time
introductory offer by saving twenty
percent off on your halo caller you have
to go to shop halo collar dot com slash
toast that's shop halo collar dot com
slash toast to save 20 off and you have
to use that link it can only be gotten
at shophalocolor.com
toast
thank you okay it's a pleasure
first story emmys
winners and losers last night was the
2021 emmys awards i'm sure majority of
you like us did not watch no but i kept
up with the winners because weirdly
enough like i watched like a good amount
of the shows that were nominated like
the crown hacks right queen's gambit so
we'll share the winners and um talk
about any standout fashions if you have
anything that stood out to you to be
honest
i want to say
that
it did feel like you know in some ways
like the emmys were so irrelevant like
there were like no a-listers there like
you know well it was just the people who
are in these shows i know it just like
felt like no one famous was there the
emmys are i mean sometimes i feel like
the emmys are like lit no i mean out of
all the
award shows is excluding the tony's no
offense um the emmys are the most
irrelevant
yeah like the golden globes
then obviously then
yeah for most relevant um in terms of
the like big ones but then they're also
every year more and more irrelevant and
like you see the ratings go down and
it's just like a big circle jerk for
these people totally you know but for
but you know but then on the other side
of the coin i was gonna say like i
actually feel like this year i was
was maybe a year i should have watched
because i was actually like invested in
a lot of the shows that were nominated
like specifically hacks but like i'm
good with just reading who won
afterwards like i don't was like
watching it on youtube you know the the
i don't need to listen to a speech not
one none not one okay zero zero zero
okay let's go through the winners drama
series best drama series that's a big
category the crown one as they should
can't go wrong with the crown can never
go wrong with the crown and you know
what like we have one season of the
crown left and they deserve all of it
until then
lead actor in a drama series josh
o'connor the crown he played prince
charles and you know what he was quite
convincing because like i literally see
that man and i want to punch him in the
neck and it's not even the real prince
charles like that's how
method acting he was he's literally
prince charles yeah lead actress in a
drama series olivia coleman the crown oh
wow is this what we call a sweep well no
well yes i guess for the drama series
it would be a sweep for these people i
feel like she's good and she's won
before jackie don't even say anything
negative i guess maybe no one else was
like better than her this year but i
feel like it could have been like it
could have been someone else no she's so
stellar she's so queeny like i love her
and she made the sweetest beach like i
actually did get teared up because like
her dad passed away like six months ago
and it was just like such a sad sweet
speech and we stand so like no olivia
coleman slander like no there was no
slander you were being slender and i
just want to say so i've been seeing
claire foy in a lot of other shows but
the first thing i ever saw her in was
the crown and she was so amazing she's
the younger she's a younger queenie and
i thought like she was the queen to me
like she was so sweet and queen-like and
everything she was great in every other
show she plays like such a wench really
it's so crazy because now i'm like oh
she's like the mean girl like she played
anne boleyn yeah uh wolf hall she also
played like this nazi sympathizing ah
awful woman in upstairs downstairs like
that's just so it's crazy it's crazy
that she even got the queen part and she
did such a good job so was this olivia
coleman's last season as the queen
because now we're changing time and we
need a gray-haired queen yes we're i
think we're we're upgrading once again
to dominic west right this is the final
and elizabeth to becky yeah yeah
it's a final casting
[Music]
british mandate
okay limited series winner was queen's
gambit i mean the queen's gamut to me is
just the gold standard of television
completely agree and anya taylor joy is
also the gr the gold standard of like
what to do when you're cast to like
a-list fame in a matter of seconds like
she's a tiffany's model and she looked
gorgeous i loved her dress the updo very
like shin young bat mitzvah i loved it
yeah she looked wonderful also all the
other limited series i haven't watched
the other ones but like mara beast town
one division like i've got such high
praise so like it was it was a
competitive competitive category as it
always is i like a limited series and
i've been meaning to watch mayor of east
town yeah me too but like it's over i
miss the hype so like who cares
oh right you already said that we have
this discussion lead actor in a limited
series or movie ewing mcgregor halston
oh wow that's so
interesting i i mean he was good
i have mixed feelings about the halston
netflix thing like
i don't even remember like enjoying it
when i watched it but now i like reflect
on it fondly if that makes sense yeah
i was nominated for like what shows paul
bettany one division hugh grant the
undoing oh lin manuel miranda hamilton
leslie odom jr hamilton is that from the
hamilton that they just do the dvr
yeah like the yeah the recording okay by
the way i think this uh absolutely
should have gone to hugh grant for the
undoing he was literally it was the best
acting performance i've ever seen
because i had no [ __ ] idea if he was
the murderer or not i agree and i didn't
think even mcgregor was that great i'm
not gonna lie i agree lead actress in a
limited series or movie kate winslet
mayor of east town of course i didn't
see it or know anything about it but the
hype
has to be real you know yeah totally
lead actress in a comedy series gene
smart hacks okay let's talk about this
like first of all so blessed grateful
and honored that hax got the credit it
deserves like it's such a good show
um jean smart is like having this
resurgence she got a standing ovation
from everyone in the room like they
would not sit down because like she's
been in this business for so long and
she just recently she lost her husband
and she like made such a sweet speech
about how like he really put his career
on the back burner so that she could
thrive and
you know have this this flourishing
career construction workers for gene
smart um and so i just [ __ ] love her
and i love the show and i can't wait for
season two and i'm so happy for like
this moment she's having yeah and she
looked sickening in this like sexy
little black thing totally love comedy
series winner ted lasso
like i was just talking to my friend
about said last night he was like you
would love it and everyone keeps saying
that but like i just can't really
express and it's really not about the
money just the principle like i'm not
subscribing to a brand new subscription
service for one show
i don't watch the morning show
so like i'm really going to pay a whole
ass service for one show a month it's
just a principle like i refuse to point
so you'll wait till they have more that
you want to see that's exactly what i
said okay that's fine yeah lead actor in
a comedy series jason sudeikis ted lasso
and in apple tv plus you can't use
someone else's login because it's like
through your own apple tv they charge
like your itunes it's only like one per
remote literally damn they got you good
they got me good but it must be really
good because supporting actress in a
comedy series hannah waddingham 10 lasso
supporting actor went to brett goldstein
ted lasso so
i'm sure it's all about ted lasso you
know it's good stuff it's good stuff
sporting actress in a limited or
anthology series or movie julia
nicholson mayor of east town supporting
actor in a limited or anthology series
or movie evan peters mayor of east town
people were really excited for him you
know the guy from sleepover of course of
course he had his moment i'm just gonna
be right back yeah we have to take care
of some business because we're
we're only on the first story so we can
sit through this for the next 50 minutes
here she goes
shut down
it's the final story
one o'clock one o'clock okay
all
right
that's a long time earlier
okay
so yeah all in all it was a really
exciting award show
and um
i actually was very pleased with the
results i'm not gonna lie
yeah well i'm glad that you enjoyed
yourself it seems like you watched the
whole thing i mean to be honest i
watched all the clips on youtube and to
be honest i think it's disgusting that
downton abbey didn't win anything well
if only like we they should be winning
attention they should be downstairs i'm
sure they all won can you look it up
downton abbey emmys
yeah i mean who do you think is like the
best actress
in the show
mr carson literally i think is the best
actor ever but the dowager if she wasn't
winning supporting
oh just she's so good
she said the funniest thing in the most
recent episode can i tell you yeah she's
always saying please remind me okay so
they're deciding between two footmen
like who's better whatever one of them
is like more hard working but the other
is like really cocky and full of
themselves but really handsome so
obviously they choose the handsome one
because you know the maids downstairs
like they need something to live for and
like they're like you know they
literally like the family told carson to
choose the handsome one and when they're
having that conversation he's like you
know in the real world like skill is
more important than beauty
and the dowager was like oh if only that
were true
it was just such an iconic moment from
an iconic [ __ ] queen so tell me who
won one 115 emmys oh by the way
something really interesting about um
the emmys last night two things one
rupaul like one again and is now the
most decorated uh emmy winner
yeah
two
the handmaid's tale set a record last
night going oh for 21. they were
nominated 21 times they did not win one
single thing and previously before that
there was a show uh that mad men
one of their seasons had been nominated
for 17 awards and not won any and that
was like the previous record but
handmaid's tale beat them out by not
winning one single award last night
that's really funny i know that's good
to know okay here's the emmys that
they've won outstanding hair styling for
a single camera series who individually
has one
outstanding production design for a
narrative period program
outstanding supporting actress in a
drama series maggie smith thank god
there were other nominees
but
like mr carson did get nominated once
but he did not win no
outstanding hair styling again actually
i feel that the hair is so ugly and like
so on on theme with the years you know
what i don't like is that like i think
for the most part they're living in the
20s and like the fashion in the 20s is
not it i'm sorry like these like drop
waist gatsby like
long beaded necklaces i hate it i know
it's like flapper yes in the you know
british aristocracy heinous you expect
them to be wearing like hoop skirts and
bonnets mary's wedding dress was
literally offensive like an atrocity it
was like this drop waste nightgown
just keep watching hopefully something's
gonna happen
oh really that nothing no like that just
only you will be so it better be about
edith because i [ __ ] hate that [ __ ]
and everything she's that's happening to
her that's called karma no and it's
called like you are leading the life
that you [ __ ] deserve because you
ratted out your family publicly and you
are literally a menace and not only are
you a menace your sister never even told
on you so your family doesn't even
really know the extent of a they don't
see you and like you are they don't even
know who you really are which is ugly
okay outstanding music composition for a
series cheers give me like outstanding
hairstyling outstanding music
composition outstanding supporting
actress again day maggie smith oh wow
outstanding costumes outstanding mini
series or movie i guess for the movie
outstanding supporting actress in a
mary's mini-series or movie day maggie
smith oh my god she's the only one who
won and she won three times outstanding
directing for a mini series or movie
outstanding writing for a mini-series or
movie outstanding cinematography for a
mini series or movie so none of the
other actors ever won they didn't want
it bad enough because maggie smith was
constantly raising the bar for everyone
that is so crazy
that is that is actually crazy someone
else like michelle dockery is
really good i can't like get a read on
michelle dockery like i kind of [ __ ]
hate her too
no i like her i feel like you'll matthew
helps like her her cause yeah and you
know that matthew
um he played the beast in beauty and the
beast oh
my god yes
oh my god you know it's been bothering
me stevens and he's in
stevens and he's in
the prince
gary gennetti prince yes and i told you
of this a few weeks ago but it didn't
mean anything to you because you weren't
a dance scene who was here in the prince
i'm obsessed with him now i think
honestly first i thought he was too ugly
to be cast in this role but now i feel
like he's really growing on me
he plays um prince charles and prince
philip not that prince phillip has lots
of lines oh my god i'm learning so much
about dan stevens i'm gonna start a dan
stevens fan account instagram like
that's how much we stan no it's crazy
how much we stand
obsessed
let's see if he was in anything else
that we love i'm sure he was he just has
like such an unremarkable face that like
i couldn't place and he wasn't really in
beauty and the beast you know
he was beauty and the beast he was like
underneath the beast like we didn't see
his face we did at the end oh right he's
wearing literally makeup all over his
face yeah he was also in eurovision i
know you saw that right the worst movie
of all time i blocked it out of my
memory oh okay fine he's in a lot of
other stuff too but nothing is so happy
for him nothing is iconic okay great i'm
so excited that you're on this downton
journey like if only we could sync up
some time let me know if you want to
start watching outlander i'll wait for
you honestly like i'm so against it but
who knows in six months i'll probably be
obsessed
okay are you ready for our next story
yeah yeah that's a good question yeah
we're switching gears completely thank
god because the body of missing woman
gabby petito believed to be found at
grand teton national park in wyoming the
fbi says okay this is the story that has
just swept the nation
the search for missing 22 year old gabby
petito had a tragic update on sunday
with the discovery of remains consistent
with the description of the long island
woman in a press conference from the
craig thomas discovery and visitor
center center in grand teton national
park charles jones the supervisory
senior resident agent in wyoming for fbi
denver confirmed human remains
consistent with the description of
petito were discovered in the vicinity
of the spread creek dispersed camping
area in wyoming jones said full forensic
identification has not been completed to
100 percent confirmed the body is that
of potato however her family was
notified of the discovery and the cause
of death has not been determined at this
time but they are examining for that
this is such a crazy story and like it's
become i mean people you know very sadly
like go missing and get murdered a lot
but this one garnered such crazy
national news because they're both like
and actually it's so crazy to watch how
much their instagrams have grown over
the last like week which is so bizarre
but they're like micro travel influence
well they're not micro anymore but
travel influencers and so like up until
recently they had been documenting their
whole journey on social media which is
now when you go back like so
like chilly yeah eerie perfect word to
go back and
look at it
and i guess there's really no way to
know how long gabby has been dead
because they were gone for so long by
the time
he drove the van back to florida
and like didn't tell anyone like where
gabby was that's when people but she we
don't know like she could have been dead
for a while like he was like posting on
her social media and honestly i've like
fallen into tick-tock um
with like so many people like discussing
this and investigating on their own i
just have to say some of these true
crime obsessed people like
are absolute lunatics and they have no
respect like for actually what's going
on and it's actually been so weird to
like see people like making all these
videos like screaming like thinking that
they solve something and like being
excited it's so weird that is really
weird no like true true crime tick tock
and like these i'm sorry women like who
think that they're doing something like
going on the
net the the national parks that they
were at like going on their facebook
pages and like literally thinking that
they're the fbi and it's like relax like
just chill the [ __ ] out like so
it's it's been interesting to see how
this is like literally become such
national news but like i also think
people are being like kind of disgusting
about it like i was just seeing so many
tick tocks that i like i just can't
believe the way people are acting i
obviously like it's not a real person
right i haven't seen the tick tocks but
the way that people you know
fancy themselves
detectives nowadays because they listen
to true crime podcasts that's like just
like an olympia is in the building where
the police officer podcasts are you
listening to justice for people who
actually solve homicides because it must
be so annoying like with the advent of
social media and this like obsession
with true crime people like really
thinking they're doing something yeah
and then okay so you didn't watch
clickbait
but um
it's kind of similar like basically
someone goes missing and they're like
dropping clues the kidnappers like
online and there's all these subreddits
and reddit threads of people like going
out and searching and like you know and
actually they do come up with like a
pretty good lead in the beginning but
like that's never how it works and
honestly like tv shows need to stop
doing that i know i mean that is
actually only murders in the building
though but i feel like it's almost like
a satire of it yes i agree and like even
their rationale for you know what
they're investigating and when is just
so silly yeah it's also such a good show
it's such a good show i'm enjoying it
immensely you know what also something
i've been like literally meaning to tell
you about about the show clickbait that
like as i was watching i'm like i can't
wait to discuss this on the toast and
then we like recapped it quickly and i
never mentioned it i really feel like
clickbait was put together
to really
highlight how unethical journalists are
like that's what was my biggest takeaway
from the show basically every episode
focuses on like a different person
involved in this case somehow whether
they're like a suspect or just like a
journalist and this journalist it was
really like the perfect metaphor for how
modern-day journalists are like they
don't give a [ __ ] about the people that
they're writing about they don't care
about actually making change they just
want to advance their own careers you
know and they and personally like they
don't right they don't care about like
the
you know the success of their newspaper
like they want the story for them so
they can and they'll step on anyone this
[ __ ] nutso journalist like broke into
the victim's house
broke into the this other random
victim's brother's house literally like
was being breaking every single law
being so [ __ ] unethical just and he
was like so self-righteous he's like i
need to do this for me like
i swear if i could reach through the
television and choke this man because he
was just the personification of
literally like the evil media like like
pretending that they're helping while
while simultaneously ruining the lives
of so many people and doing it in the
most unethical way possible
just for them for themselves like not
for any other purpose not for any
greater thing
behind the the cause the cause yeah but
then at the end of the day it's just so
they can you know be the on-camera
person and they can get the promotion
and they can like interview
it was that was my takeaway i don't know
if that's what everyone's takeaway was
but i like watching this episode i swear
my blood was boiling i mean it's always
like that especially in crime
things i'll never forget that that thing
i never saw the show that you were
talking about the assassination of
gianni versace lee miglin because they
like the news broke the news that he was
um in this
certain kind of car
and
he was us he had to get a new car and he
murdered someone to get to take their
car to take their car so literally lee
was responsible for well no lee i'm
sorry
here
andrew cunanan who's the murderer of
gianni versace murdered lee miglin took
lee miglin's car the news reported that
he's in lee miglin's car it looks like
this look out so andrew cannon parks
dumps the car murders someone else and
takes his truck no the media is [ __ ]
evil like [ __ ] evil
so sorry for that
it's just been bothering me because i
wanted to talk about it yeah well this
story has really captured a lot of
people's attention especially in the
toaster groups i mean everyone's talking
about it so hopefully and now brian the
fiancee is missing
well not missing is what gabby's family
is saying which
tracks so hopefully they're able to find
him too because he would have answers
but also when they do
um forensic autopsy on her body they
will be able to tell when she
died so that should provide some answers
too yeah there's just like so much
weirdness about and there's also so much
like footage because they're influencers
but then also like
a couple weeks ago like early august
they were pulled over and he had like
all these bruises on him
and like i guess like the police were
doing like some sort of wellness check
and there's like all this body camera
footage of like him talking about
you know gabby and like talking to the
police and like being like so chill and
weird it's so bizarre and this is just
like one of those things where just like
everyday people become murderers and
it's [ __ ] weird yeah
and then it's also just like a very
scary reminder like you really never
know who you're sleeping next to
are you ready for our next story
switching gears once again switching
gears to a story that's brought to you
by betterhelp yes is there something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
well betterhelp will assess your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional therapist where you can
start communicating in 48 hours there is
a broader range of expertise available
which may not be local
locally available to you in many areas
here's how it works you can log into
your account anytime and send a message
to your therapist you get a timely and
thoughtful response plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as you do
with traditional therapy betterhelp is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change therapists if needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline therapy and financial aid is
available
so many people have been using
betterhelp that they are recruiting
additional therapists in all 50 states
so we have a special offer for the
morning toast listeners if you want to
get 10 off your first month go to
betterhelp.com toast that's
betterhealth.com
toast thank you bravo has axed this
season's real house as of new york
reunion this is historic bravo confirmed
that there will not be a reunion for
this season due to scheduling changes
around the taping of the reunion for the
real house eyes of new york city in a
timely manner so i was under the
impression that they had filmed
something like a couple weeks ago
and now they were just like canning it
but i actually now think that they
didn't even film anything
yeah they wouldn't waste all that budget
well first of all you said it was remote
so that's less budget did i say that
yeah when they were supposed to be
filming it was going to be remote which
was weird like annie didn't want i must
have heard that somewhere because i
don't i don't claim that
at all like
i don't even know what you're talking
about that's what you said which tracked
also
um
yeah if it hasn't been filmed by now and
it's already been two weeks and then it
takes a couple weeks to package yeah
like no thank you i mean i'm
grateful
so grateful i'm grateful i'm definitely
worried for this franchise but there is
nothing to to talk about really we could
go over some of the fights that were had
but you know what when most of the time
most of the people were drunk and
wouldn't stand by what they said and we
just apologize and all like they're just
all so messy like i mean i guess this
officially makes it the worst season of
housewives ever because even the most
recent season of oc which was really bad
even they had a two-part reunion and
honestly it wasn't terrible it wasn't
terrible and like
they're rebuilding the franchise like
heather's coming back there's all this
stuff going on but even they had a
reunion so i think that this officially
marks it the worst season of housewives
ever we've never not had a reunion even
for the dullest of seasons i agree and
it really was that just
nothing really awful the fact that the
the season finale was a party in
ramona's house with everyone having
their tits out pin the tail on the
doobin
pathetic that's when you that's the
lowest point and i don't know rock
bottom i feel like we talk about this
all the time but like i don't even know
the proper
solution here like i almost think like
everyone goes every single person and
like we just i can't claim any of that
negative energy like
even like even when leah came like leah
was so cool and like the show was just
so losery it made lea like into a loser
yeah the show is like it the the
reputation it's like just terrible like
even if a cool person comes on i don't
think bethany would fix it i don't think
dorinda would fix it i don't think
tinsley would fix it like i think it's
just time for fresh it is and maybe we
would get you know
actually wealthy people or just like
younger
women who
are hungry are for
fame fame so they'll do the stuff that
women used to do on season one and we
could go back to that but also i think
the shows are have just become like a
little too formulaic yeah and sometimes
like you can't
it's just like a beast that it created
you know i don't know how
i also think i think you're right it's
so formulaic and like at some point like
your some franchises just expire
yeah and i feel like oc expired and i
feel like
new york expired and i feel like potomac
is at like their best because they're
like five years younger maybe maybe more
like seven years younger than other
franchises and so they're still like
fresh and ripe and atlanta's getting
like kind of dull but salt lake city so
good like i think like eventually maybe
you retire franchise for a couple years
and then bring it back and do like
something else in the meantime because
11 12 13 seasons the only one that's
able to survive that is beverly hills
and that's for obvious reasons like
they're actually wealthy and there's
always [ __ ] scandals going on yeah
but you can't expect like there to be
magic with a group of women who i'm
sorry are not wealthy and
they just get drunk and who whose sole
income really is the show and the and
the things that branch off from it so
like
they're acting at this point like
there's no
heart there's there's it's just and
they're not even friends like and but
they also like are not even enemies yeah
like they don't even care anymore they
don't care they just want to put on a
show i agree with you that maybe it's
total clean slate though there was the
rumor that they were going to get rid of
everyone but keep ramona and ebony i
would be down for that too i would
be very happy with and i'm sorry like
the way that everyone hates ramona like
talk about the only interesting thing
walking through the doors this season
was ramona and like she's nuts and she's
hilarious and she's funny and like
and the way that everyone is just so
mean to her because they think like the
audience hates her and they just don't
want to be like on team ramona i'm sorry
ramona's everything of the sort and i
will not accept ramona slander anymore
no i will not i've stopped putting up
with ramona slender a while ago and it's
it's really a great place to be i
recommend that you all try it but
ramona like is the heart and soul of the
show because she's not just like
off the walls crazy like sonia she's not
she's actually very lucid yeah so
sometimes sometimes no but then she has
her crazy moments and then it's like but
we need more women like ramona perfect
who have the heart and soul and like
really balanced like are
invested in female friendships but also
sometimes they lose it go bananas yeah
totally like you have to do both you
can't always be going bananas
you can't always be perfect and boring
boring because and you want a good edit
yeah that's like a little like ebony
like she's like a little boring and
perfect yeah
she never got like down and dirty with
it yeah but nothing to get down in i
wouldn't say that any of the new york
like they're just a mess but i do feel
like there are housewives that come on
that are just like
they're too scared of any sort of
backlash they're just they won't
do anything you can't be they won't step
out of line you know
so you need people who are a little bit
crazy yeah and honestly i just i'm it's
not surprising that there's no reunion i
just like that's never happened before
so it's historic it's historic and i'm
feeling very personally grateful what
happened to class
elegance okay next story the seven
husbands of christina hack she posted oh
my god this was an update about like the
seven of husbands of evelyn hugo like
being made into a movie or something not
exactly [ __ ] christie yeah she's
definitely engaged right right right
right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right jose deletes another ring with
joshua another ring pick with joshua
hall so she she's so thirsty i can't
posted a picture of her on her instagram
of the two of them a selfie and she put
a heart over her ring finger
it was a high so not subtle like it was
so intentional she could have easily
like had not the heart and we saw the
ring and then she's like promising or
whatever or she like just moved her hand
or could have moved put her popsicle
down yeah or could just come out with
her engagement no like i don't
i don't even care if she's engaged
because like this is
at first like this little like
love rhombus between the hacks the
moosas and steads and steads was
interesting and now it's kind of
bordering on sad and honestly i don't
think it's fair for aunt downstate to be
bringing renee zellweger into this this
is like this is becoming like twisted
like i know and i know that you think so
but just
i actually never watch flipper flop i
it's the most toxic [ __ ] show i i
really
never invested much in like tark and
christina and i never really cared about
the rhombus until recently but just the
fact that like every year christina has
like a new husband it's actually [ __ ]
crazy it's impressive no i know like she
must be like you know
like have the best game like she knows
how to text like she's getting all these
men she just like dropped down on when
he proposed like have children with her
buy homes with her and then she's like
bye i don't know what is going on with
christina hack but i think we could all
learn a few things from her i agree
i agree and she's um this would be her
third marriage in like three years right
and so like i she could be evelyn hugo
no the seven husbands of christina hack
was the perfect way of putting this like
but it's not seven it's gonna be like
35. if she keeps going straight yeah and
like honestly no shade not at all
respect
impressive
it's [ __ ] crazy like she definitely
is engaged like it was such an obvious
stupid move like like we're in middle
school like
like you're engaged who cares um
they probably have like some people
exclusive people magazine is just like
eating this like rhombus up oh okay i'm
happy for them yeah i'm actually reading
it in page six this is like their go-to
like stupid ass drama yeah and then
sometimes they throw heather and tarek's
cupcakes in oh my god there's always
something stupid going on with them
they did their joint bachelor
bachelorette party there's so much
there's so much money we should actually
change it to heather and tarik's
mindless news there's so much
mindlessness they're going
they're going vegan
the only thing i'll say is that to me i
have no questions why there's mindless
news about them like they're putting it
out there that's how they propel their
career they're really not like a-listers
or anything and like you know we post an
instagram us weekly writes it up that's
the ecosystem that we live in it doesn't
make sense for kelly ripa she's too
famous for that she's so famous she's so
legitimate like i think we got down to
the bottom of it actually last week when
we she's trying to deflect the narrative
she's trying to undo the did that she
did you know yeah when it came to the
michael strahan drama of it all like
nobody wants to be remembered for having
a tantrum because your co-worker who
deserved his promotion got one like
you're a jealous wench so now i don't
think jealous wench when i think kelly
ripa i think gorgeous you know like
stein goya dress
and i just think like mindless always
commenting on her kids instagram like
you know just something
mindless no i'm always thinking like oh
her and mark being thirsty again like
that's and you know what that's not a
great association but it's better than
the michael strahan drama yeah she's
working her way up it's actually pretty
[ __ ] smart it is and i feel like now
she's like in like a hamster wheel where
like if she stops the mindless shoes it
was probably like a temporary fix like a
like not a permanent solution but now
it's like she's been doing it for so
long that she's afraid if she gets off
the hamster wheel like they'll go back
to talking about michael strand so she's
actually just gonna be doing this until
like the day she dies that's awful yeah
her publicist so we're making bank yeah
that's true
are you ready for our fifth and final
story already
all ready
it's the final story
[Music]
[Music]
oh that felt good yeah what's the final
story it's some historic space news
because the spacex's inspiration for all
civilian orbital mission
has landed safely off the coast of
florida everyone's smiling happy 200
million raised for saint jude's oh it's
historic fabulous
i'm sorry saint jude's is a fabulous
organization they are their commercials
always make me cry but i've heard so
many wonderful things about saint jude's
like justice for st jews and spacex's
inspiration for is providing justice and
funding for saying jesus that's so great
like that 200 million dollars is going
to make such a difference yeah and four
private citizens went to space safely
came home like live to tell the tale and
this could you know
pioneer private space travel as we
discussed last week
but i'm just i'm happy that everyone's
home safely maybe it does influence you
know my decision a little bit do you
think in like 100 years like this is
going to be in a textbook
i always think about that like when
historic [ __ ] happens it depends what
textbook you know if it's the general
history of the world u.s history
um
i feel like it may be in like a really
dense one
that's what i'm saying yeah if it's very
general no
it's not gonna be an armstrong on the
moon right like what do you think is
something that has happened this year
that like will be oh my god where do i
begin oh obviously like besides covid
like mexi would be in a textbook you
think
not in our textbook not in our textbook
no in a british royal history one they
probably got a footnote oh by the way
that's the other thing about downton
abbey i'm so sorry i need to bring it up
and i'm sorry this is not gonna spoil
anything but in the time period that
we're
i'm currently watching it's a spanish
flu and by the way the show was made
long before covid and honestly watching
it in a covered world was so
eerie like
they were talking about
the flu and like the
symptoms and the contagiousness and i
swear to god they could have been
talking about covet it was so creepy
like how you know this one guy you know
we have to be aware of him he has got
you know not strong lungs like it was
just so weird and then like they bounced
back like a couple years later and it
just like gave me hope like i feel like
a lot of times and the media is
responsible for making making us feel
this way like we're never going to get
out of this and like the world is over
as we know it and honestly like just
seeing the crown no not the crown
downton abbey like you know get through
it really gave me hope you know when you
watch like a lot of pair of pieces
there's so much plague there's so many
pandemics like if you watch the news
like them fear-mongering us into like
never leaving our homes again i'm like
oh my god like that is the world like
we're never gonna get over this but the
outlook like when you watch something
like downtown like the outlook is just
so different than the one that we have
now yeah but also like they did breeze
through it in one episode and like of
course you know getting through a
pandemic does take longer than one
episode but i don't know it was just
like a totally it was so crazy how they
were referring to this
disease and it was literally covered
yeah i mean i guess covet is a flu so
it's like they're similar
right yeah
so
that's that on that festive stories you
definitely needed to know them congrats
to all of the new astronauts who've
landed so happy for you guys exciting
let's dive into the tv recap segment so
much to this which is uh let's get our
potomac one out of the way because
honestly nothing happened and it was
filled with so much mindless personal
news of people i don't care about robin
and her warehouse gisele and her kids
getting their permits
right now
i did like you know i skipped through
the commercial break and then i saw it's
like a personal scene from giselle so i
just like go one more and then i watch
like most of it but i gave it like a
little you know sometimes when i'm
watching somebody really good i want to
get to the right to the beginning with a
commercial
where i was when chris showed up at the
at the music video set i pressed yeah
and i saw that i missed a line went back
to commercials watch more commercials so
that i can make sure i heard the whole
thing so there's really only two things
worth talking about the chris thing but
then also i kind of feel like it's this
whole candle thing is actually kind of
like might blow up because like
i 100 believe that karen was working on
these candles long before wendy even had
the idea and wendy's
a mess like she has what 15 candles
karen they said they're ready for retail
like they have labels they have
everything and i just feel like wendy is
gonna be kerfuffled and like say
something to karen which is moronic
because first of all grand tom is a
fragrance company like from a fragrance
obviously candles is like a logical
number she's in the business of sense
it's uh it's such a beautiful and i
actually felt like karen wasn't being
that rude about it like she could have
been more shady but she was like you
know hers is one wick perfect for a
powder room and mine is three wicks for
a bigger room like i feel like she could
have been like ruder but i do think
wendy's gonna make something about that
and like even just like i'm sorry wendy
went from being someone who like i
really admired to like i'm sorry her
business is a joke like no the way that
she like jokes around with eddie and her
stupid presentations like it's stupid
was doing that presentation i was like
how many degrees does she have no
totally no i'm asking you like four she
has four degrees and all of a sudden
she's cameron west got trying to sell
sparkle dog to court no it's literally
like she's just like
cow towing to her husband like putting
together these presentations that have
absolutely no [ __ ] data in them like
she doesn't know how much her candle
costs like i don't know i'm just like
she went from being someone like who was
really accomplished and she still is but
i'm like but what the [ __ ] are you doing
no and also why is she playing it this
way like when they asked she's making
yourself look stupid in the interview
and they're like what how much have you
spent so far and she was like i need to
add up my excel spreadsheet i need to
add up the comments on my spell
spreadsheet which is like i understand
what you mean but like can you give us a
rough like the answer to that is not
like i need to add up my columns right
she's just like how much have you spent
no it's so
thousand dollars right i'm like 15 000
like i it was just it sounded based on
like what she said it sounded like
receipts for like
things that she bought at the store to
make a candidate did she make the
candles herself i feel like she spent
like a hundred dollars yeah me too like
on supplies and anyways just like give a
number don't like i don't know why she's
doing this doing it in this way it's so
counter to how she presented herself in
the past right which is what jason was
saying um okay
gisele hasn't even seen this yet no
totally and gizelle's talking about
physical but i'm really talking about
like you went from being someone who
almost was like so condescending with
her career to like
starting from scratch no wendy's was the
only personal scene that i watch and she
should have wished i didn't 100 because
i've really been enjoying her this
season and now i'm so confused i also
did watch a bit of a bit of um giselle
teaching her daughter how to drive just
because i do feel like personally
invested in someone's journey
and i always you know i want to see
other
drivers
other aspiring drivers succeed um and
maybe i could learn a thing or two but
gisele's gucci fiat is something worth
discussing you said it's jamal's car
didn't she say like when she pulled up
in that fiat like last season and
candace was like what is that car she's
like oh it's jamal's when he's in town
something like that but but i can't
imagine jamal driving that car no she's
always driving it and it never really
dawned on me until i saw the gucci seats
that this is the car that she drives and
actually did a little bit of research
because i just assumed like she took it
to you know the body shop and said like
make it gucci gucci but no there is a
gucci fiat model they did a
collaboration and that is a real car
it's atrocious it's literally first of
all i just think fiats are the ugliest
cars like i'm sorry
i just don't understand the tiny car
extravaganza if you watch the italian
job no you'll have more appreciation
okay but then like the seat belts and
then like that stripe around the car
it's that happens to be my least
favorite gucci print like that green and
red stripe i just think it's heinous and
i don't mind it's even uglier in a car
no it's crazy like all so many people
and even you go to like um
salt lake city and like gen shaw's like
labels labels labels labels labels
labels like nobody has the label on
their car no it's
it's ostentatious on another level
last night was the first time that it
dawned on me what we were seeing and i
was really just like i've noticed it
before and i did think to myself she
definitely had those seat belts put in
because i was like i never noticed the
seat belt saying oh i did i i only
noticed the strike around the car but
like i never think it wasn't until you
like you texted me about it last night
and then you found the link for the i
said we need to talk about should we get
one we need to talk about giselle's
gucci fiat and you said it's a
conversation worth having it's the
craziest [ __ ] heart
insanity
um and then like the big moment was this
event now i have a few things to say uh
mia like asking questions to
candace's mom like i kind of would have
done the same and candace's mom is like
honestly like i don't even like candace
but for her own mom like on tv she does
not stop like she was starting
conversations with everyone yeah but who
was it who went over to candace was it
robin who's like mia wendy
so [ __ ] losery of wendy i'm sorry so
wrong so here's the thing i don't think
mia should have been i mean it's not
really
polite to be asking those questions
especially when we're on set for this
thing but i'm glad she did we're
watching a show someone's got to do it
and i am curious if he's on salary and i
also and i'm sure i hadn't thought about
it before but it's clear that all the
women were thinking about it so she's
asking what everyone's thinking and
that's fine respect and i also
understand why wendy is like this is so
inappropriate like what candace's thing
why are we talking about but for wendy
to go and tell candace and to ruin her
when candace is already like stressed
the [ __ ] out trust the [ __ ] out the fact
that candace didn't shed a tear the
whole evening admirable um a newfound
respect the fact that she could even
like hug and jump on her husband after
the end of the shoot
him walking out in those striped pants i
was like
this i like hate him no but like she
does not pay her husband right that's
what they never really said but i'm
guessing no he just like
if she wins he wins you know well you
get what you pay for right and
they should the fact that they had to
use like karen's heart karen's car and
like everyone's cars was like
embarrassing and also like they're i'm
so confused by their situation so
apparent right but also at the same time
when they were waiting for the cars it
was like a graffitied out car they were
waiting for the cars and i was like all
these women just pulled up in stunning
cars like when ain't gonna realize you
just just use them yeah so i'm glad
karen drives maserati yeah i'm glad that
they put that together
but i don't understand their situation
so he doesn't work at the restaurant
anymore no so that's why he's working
for candace and now we're going to put
all of our eggs in but he's also doing
like at-home virtual cooking classes oh
i thought he was taking a cooking class
and i'm like no i think he's giving them
no okay yeah yeah that means 100 and i
think he like is doing private cooking
for other people yeah yeah yeah okay
that makes more sense but still you've
got to get your ducks in order it was
just and i have to be honest like i do
hate giselle but she did have like one
really redeeming moment where like
wendy's all you know clamped that mia's
talking to candace's mom so you know
wendy runs over to robin and giselle was
like can you believe that mia just asked
candace's mom if you know chris is being
paid and just i was like well is he like
we're curious like what is the setup i
thought the same thing
i mean robin was just like so in the
background the whole episode like i
don't even i don't claim robin like i
just i i hate her
i really [ __ ] hate her um and karen
remains like supreme she's a queen i
absolutely [ __ ] love everything she
does i would watch literally like a home
scene of her clipping her toenails like
i just love her yeah
and that's not on that that said on that
the music video like i guess it turned
out cute in the end the autobody shop
episode segment looked cool yeah it did
but like just the whole scene waiting
for the sunset was like tragic and then
like she had this like love interest it
was turned but they were only like
hugging and chris was watching and like
it just it smelled to me like justice
for monique
that's
that is what it smelled like i can
confirm
and
ashley like yes oh actually didn't have
to do that
there wasn't even a chair they were
standing in the parking lot where they
were sitting in their cars yeah torture
torch justice for ashley a hundred
percent
so that was and and and we got some
entertainment value and candace got her
music video so like i don't even feel
bad like laughing it's just like my my
opinions on everyone is changing so much
like now this week i hate wendy and i
like kind of like candice
yeah no candace has grown on me whereas
last week i really did like
wendy i was like proud of her for
standing up like wendy and giselle yeah
but that's also what i mean it makes a
good franchise it's like your feelings
about people should constantly be in
flux when you're so certain this one's
the villain and that one's like the best
person then you're waiting for that
person to go but it's like it's good
when you're like okay i agree with this
it's always good to have like a favorite
like you can do no wrong but like i
agree with this person about these
things i disagree about other things it
just makes the show more interesting
that's true and i have to say i'm
incredibly excited for next week where
it appears like gisele's home is the
subject of some ridicule as it should be
like having guests over and there's like
a tractor
digging up dirt in your front yard yeah
no next week does look pretty good we
always say that and karen got vaccinated
so that's all that matters right also
one other thing that i was going to say
i forgot it was a pretty good episode it
was filled with a lot of like boring oh
mia is two different people she's the
mia that we see on the show and then
she's in me and her confessionals
yeah she's like shady and funny in her
confession it's like where's that girl
and she's like so confident and like and
strong and then in the show she's
violent
like who are her friends even spineless
giving bronwyn season one energy yeah
i'm just like so confused by her i love
confessional mia i can i completely i
don't know mia on the show she's just
like thirsty for everyone to like her
which is just like a nice personality
trait in real life but not on a real
reality show yeah you have to you know
if you stand for nothing you fall for
everything exactly
um and then the salt lake city recap
which is so exciting is brought to you
by pros
after your pregnancy your body shifting
recalibrating and doing things that
don't feel normal and one of the
alarming side effects of all the
hormonal changes can be excessive
shedding hair that comes out in clumps
even when you wash or brush it and
thankfully pros is here to help stop the
shedding cycle and grow back your hair
pros specializes in custom hair care and
now they also make custom hair
supplements that are personally tailored
to address your specific cause of
shedding they take into account things
like hormonal changes stress level diet
and more
the result is customized supplements
guaranteed to help your hair grow
thicker longer softer and in more record
time they're made with clean safe and
natural ingredients and the pros hair
supplements are just two capsules you
take daily better yet pro supplements
are free from drugs synthetic fillers
and dht hormones all formulas are
gluten-free dairy-free nut-free vegan
and cruelty-free
try your own custom hair supplements and
you'll get 15 off when you go to
pros.com toast that's p-r-o-s-e dot com
toast for your free in-depth hair
consultation and 15 off custom hair
supplements check it out
okay salt lake city was so good like i
just i could watch it's the actual like
total opposite of atomic i could watch
the personal scenes forever like i
really feel like these women are just
so interesting
and i was actually getting so angry at
last night's episode i'm sorry lisa
barlow is such a bad [ __ ] friend i
cannot get over it and i was also
getting frustrated because as much as i
love heather like she's so desperate
it's like it's unbecoming of her like
yeah she's this confident queen i feel
like why everyone loves her like she's
so sure of herself she takes no [ __ ]
but when it comes to jen shaw she's a
loser like yeah i it's so upsetting i
think she's about to have a big fall
from grace me too because now even in
real life now we know that like lisa
barlow even comes to terms with the fact
that she can't be friends with jen shawn
she's like completely not talking to
jensha where's heather and her are
better friends than ever like she needs
to be there for jen while she's going
through all this [ __ ] yeah and heather
said on watch what happens live which i
didn't understand
at the time and then i watched it
further where she always knew like jen's
business was on savory but she didn't
know it was illegal so i do think this
whole time she knew that jen was um
getting people to buy into like some
sort of fake scam and also selling their
information once they bought it and i
think heather knew that that was what
her business was did not know that that
was the legal crime
so that's why she feels the need to
stand
with her because she's like there's no
new information i'm sorry there's
literally no excuse to stand with john
shaw no there's none whatsoever and
just in the first two episodes i'm
already feeling like heather is sort of
slipping it's giving me leah vibes where
it's like last season you're just here
to zero and now it's like
with each episode i'm just like i agree
with you less and less like and she
really like in that conversation that
the two of them had at that point she
was like all she's asking is that jen
doesn't lie to her about like getting
hacked or said or like the screen shots
photoshop she could still say horrible
things about me on social media but as
long as she owns up to it right like you
said all these horrible things you don't
need to explain yourself or apologize
for them i just need you to not say them
anymore and and not act as if they're
photoshopped it was like a conversation
so [ __ ] low and whitney would have
been vomiting because whitney was
actually giving heather good advice
whitney knew exactly what was going to
go on whitney knew heather was going to
walk in there and just be like under jen
spell and be like obsessed and desperate
to be her friend and when he was like at
least try and give her a hard time and
she didn't and whitney's gonna watch
that scene that was heather trying to
give her a hard time the fact that she
like you know waited two beats before
she accepted jen back into her life and
the fact that jen like makes everything
like she's like treated differently in
the group when it's like you are given
such a pass that's exactly actually what
heather said yes that is what heather
said but it's like for your temper you
everyone walks on egg shells around you
because you have such a crazy temper
right you go so crazy with people and
like you really don't apologize and you
just like continue to do it again and
then you're upset when you feel
alienated from the group but it's like
why would this group want to wow more of
that no totally it's delusion and it's
it's such narcissism like not being able
to see anything other than like the way
you feel when it's like you don't even
acknowledge the fact that like what
she's doing to meredith and brooks and
you know how like i'm
not even a fan of brooks but like
what she's doing is so evil to someone's
kid and she keeps comparing like he said
something about my vagina he's a child
first of all so like you don't get to go
head tit-for-toe with him like tiff or
chat with him at all and second okay you
made your point you were annoyed that he
said something about your vagina and you
made your point but like you don't stop
and now we're bordering on homophobic
slurs right and also it looks like next
week she says that she doesn't run her
twitter account so she has one of her
interns or whatever who's liking tweets
and retweeting stuff and and whatnot but
like the directive comes from jen
whoever
they don't
it starts at the top it's so stupid like
what a lame excuse no it's such a
cowardice like no one believes that be
like but i will say one nice thing um
jen looked so sickening i was igloo oh
not even in the igloo i also thought
when she was at home calling heather she
just looked gorgeous what was she
wearing i don't know but it was like her
glam and her face were like just
snatched i don't know if she had any
work done but like her hair looked
amazing i actually thought and yes her
fur outfit at the glacier was so cute
that's when i touched she's best dressed
i'm going to her estate sale if she gets
convicted and i'm getting that hat and
the code yeah no by the way that's
actually a great [ __ ] call we're
gonna go to utah um okay the other thing
was actually weirdly enough i know
mary's like so not in the storyline but
that scene where she was remodeling her
home was so funny like when she's
talking about how her cousin who's the
worst contractor in the world like if
you want something done don't go to him
like so funny and then commenting on her
green carpet and her ugly sconces like
we love a queen who can poke fun at
herself it was it was so refreshing and
mary also looks different mary like
looks her face looks like maybe she got
some filler she looked great yeah i mean
it in a positive way but the shows are
becoming not so much salt lake city but
potomac for sure where it's like
45 of the episode is personal scenes and
then we get the women together for the
last fifteen percent and it's like what
happened to lunches what happened to
elegance
what they keep doing like flashbacks to
lunches that we didn't see
i want more breakout lunches and that's
why the group trips are so great because
like there's no person four hours of
group scenes
like no even last week when we had four
women out of lunch like perfect it
doesn't always need to be the whole
group sometimes two sometimes three mix
it up interesting things get shared in
those lunches i completely agree i won't
fast forward through a lunch never you
know so
i that's my request these two and maybe
it's like a covid symptom but like it's
like everybody has their own personal
crap that they're promoting and we
really don't care we really don't care
we're they're explaining to their
husbands what happened what we already
saw right right we have to hear
regurgitated
i'm good
no and then the group gets together in
the words of my favorite tic toc sound
we really don't give a [ __ ] it's not a
major holiday okay like it's enough
it's not a major holiday um
it's i know you don't know but it's the
best tic toc sound it's this girl's like
it's st patrick's day we really don't
give a [ __ ] it's not a major holiday
it's literally the best tic toc sound
but you wouldn't know because you
refused to conform no i wouldn't know
because you only send me bad tick tocks
i just feel like it's not my
responsibility to
like cater to you then don't send me any
but you only send me bad ones you don't
send me cool trendy like anything if you
don't say like this is what everyone's
doing how funny is that whatever um all
in all salt lake city was pretty good
and meredith is a queen she was on watch
she happens live with candace and andy
and like the thing that went viral from
the episode is andy asked her like did
you call the feds and i think she said
this is a joke but she was like and
everyone's been asking her that like i
saw she did press for the show
entertainment tonight she said of course
not but andy said did you
contact the feds and meredith said well
i warned you guys not to mess with my
family
but i do think she was kidding oh i
don't think that she did me neither
you're saying she's she has said that
she didn't multiple times like and i do
believe she was joking yeah but i'm
sorry like i [ __ ] love queen meredith
and i've heard people say like you know
meredith is getting a big head because
like now everyone's obsessed with her
and i'm sorry like she's entitled to the
big head and we love her and you're
completely right heather gay is having a
liam mcsweeney moment yeah because i'm
i'm starting to hate heather and for a
while i thought there was no one in the
world i would want to hang out with more
i don't think there was ever a housewife
who had a better seat first season than
liam mcsweeney and a worse second season
well heather gay is about to give leo a
run for her money
that's what i'm thinking um so that is
our show that was a tv recap
and i do believe that soul she wrote
that's all she wrote um i didn't watch
anything else i finished with lularoe
oh yeah what did you think
my thoughts
you guys couldn't handle my phone no you
couldn't i think you should say them
um i'll think about it i just want you
to know that it's probably my hottest
take
ever no and you know what like with mlms
like people do not [ __ ] around like if
you like even want to say one thing in
defense of like the company like you're
you don't support other women so i just
want to say before jackie says if she
says these are jackie's thoughts not
mine i just want to say like i facetimed
you and told you my thoughts and you no
i don't disagree with your thoughts
because i do feel like the problem with
mlms is like there's no personal
accountability yeah it's just like the
company made me do this but you also
showed up and did all that right and
also like you were saying so many of
these companies are like a really big
issue is how much inventory you have to
buy at the outset you can't get into it
without spending five thousand dollars
or ten thousand dollars and it's like
well then don't get into it like it's
not like you sign something and then
you're fine and then you find out you
have to spend all this money it's like
in order to get into it you have to
spend all this money so like that's the
time to say no no i completely agree
with you and like that's and there is no
personal accountability especially with
like i feel like in some of the um
testimonials we watched on the
documentary like some of the women like
really you know they kind of destroyed
their own lives with getting carried
away with stuff and like my question is
like when if you took out a credit card
to buy that 5 000 inventory like that
one woman who who got divorced and
everything she was so sad she was so sad
and it really felt like she it was so
hard on herself because of it yeah and
so i'm not talking about her but like if
you took but she took out a credit card
and then she started making bank from
lularoe bought herself two cars
was the first thing she did not pay off
those debts i sure hope so i don't know
it sounded like no yes she didn't say so
i have to assume and then like she lost
her cars and she lost her house because
like she had all these debts but she was
making so much money right
no i don't know like and you shouldn't
take out a credit card ever you should i
you shouldn't you know spend money that
you don't have especially to buy
inventory to join an mlm like no um but
if you do and and you start making tens
of thousand dollars a month you should
pay that off you know i i think your
sentiment that i i really agree with at
the end of the day is like of course
mlms are bad and their pyramid schemes
are illegal for a reason but at the end
of the day like
it wasn't this thing where people you
know were forced into sl saying
selling lularoe like out of their own
free will people decided to spend the
money join and for a while it was really
good and then it wasn't and i'm not
talking about like
of course when they started selling
faulty stuff and not refunding people
i'm not talking about issues that i'm
like the the defective the smelly the
this that that you can't send back no
that is bad business practice not
different and they should be sued for
that and they were and yes people
hopefully got their money right and they
should have been refunding that from the
from the beginning yes because that's
really [ __ ] disgusting but when we
talk about like the culture around
lularoe and how like all these they're
still people who sell lularoe and all
these you know former lularoe girls like
you're crazy you're in a cult like
this might be a very hot take but i
think you've said this before just
because you make something into a cult
doesn't make it a cult right just
because you treat you got sucked into
something like nobody was forcing you to
do anything like you made it your entire
life and now you're embarrassed and so
you want to turn around and take a [ __ ]
on the whole thing and call it you know
these crazy extreme terms doesn't make
it those crazy extreme terms yeah so
that was like the one thing i didn't
like about the documentary was like
i don't know how to say it it's like i
don't really feel like
for a while lularoe was a bad thing no
they were they were mishandled of course
because these two people mark and dean
don't know how to run a business let
alone a billion dollar business and
there were also there was those product
issues that we've discussed there were
definitely ethical things like there
were times which we discussed retiring
husbands and like the sort of the home
woman like yeah give everything to your
husband right but like these are grown
women as they said so many times on the
show college educated you know like they
have families like there is it's and
they they enter into something and you
should be able to parse out you know
this part piece i like this piece i
don't yeah so i just don't think it's
fair to say that like because you are
carried away and you're in this
situation like and you mark yourself in
something yeah like i don't know i just
didn't agree and also that it's mlms in
general because mlms are legal
and a lot of people really enjoy i mean
i mean every single there's so there's
millions of people involved in mlms and
like they're entering on their own like
so there's obviously some merit to them
especially if you like the product now
you that you everyone keeps saying the
issue is you shouldn't get paid for
you shouldn't have to pay to get
started and you should you have to buy
the product if you want to sell it and
you shouldn't have to um
you really can't be
making money based on how many people
you bring into the company that's what i
was going to say the second part but
having to buy the product in order to
sell it like yeah and you know what if
you want
the barrier to entry is kind of high and
that should actually push people away
from doing it you know so the the
crazier it is like the more you'd be
like why the [ __ ] would i do that so if
you want to if you're
really want to do it fine no the second
piece is like that you make money based
on other people's purchases because
there's a difference between making
money for recruiting someone just
bringing them in because when you work
at a big corporation and you refer you
get a bonus job you got a big fat
referral bonus
is that a pyramid scheme that's actually
a very interesting point so if you bring
someone in to the mlm they start selling
you should get a one-time if if that's
how the business wants to
do you get a one-time referral bonus
that's a normal business practice yeah
you shouldn't be making money off of
what their sales have spent that's
unethical you're right right so but like
it does seem like there are ways to have
an app like there's a reason why there
should be a way to have an ethical mlm
that's successful that like yes the
people who were early days people first
employees at google make way more no
they're retired they own islands in the
south of france like then the the you
know the 8 000 employee then the 10 000
employee no i agree and honestly like of
course at the there are like toxic
things that go on in mlms but i just
think like the documentary was just
taking major
what's the phrase
when you take
it's not advantage but like thank you
but like
when you like say something that's like
liberties yes oh my god you're a queen
like i just think they were taking
liberties in like the blame like of
course the the company was faulty and
but i think that like if you
got to like such a bad place like it's
not mark and dm's not everything can be
mark and dan's fault where's the
personal accountability yes and also
if we are grown educated women who out
on our own volition entered into this
like we are not robots if there is
something more nefarious about mlms and
what i'm understanding i just watched a
whole documentary that attempted to
explain it to me so why didn't it come
through that's on the documentary if
there's like more no but and i'm sure
people message me but no but like
lularoe was doing this i'm like then why
wasn't that in the four-part documentary
that i [ __ ] sat through on amazon
prime a company with a very questionable
business practices
towards their lower level employees
that's true
so that's jackie's hot take on mlms
honestly don't add us like just let it
go okay
unless you agree with us um
that's our show everyone hope you have
an amazing day we'll see you tomorrow
thank you so much for listening to the
morning toast millennial morning show
where we deliver the fast fast stories
that you need to know every monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up most available podcasts
anywhere podcasts can be found so it's a
spotify itunes stitch or public video i
have rated of catastrophes all the
places regulation podcast find out the
morning chosen leave a five star view
about how beautiful stunning and smart
we are and if you've still made it to
the end of this episode congratulations
you are now a part of the society season
two and to let us know that you are true
toaster who listens to the end of the
episodes drop an emoji on our most
recent instagram how about the crown
because we've talked a lot about royalty
the crown downton abbey give me a crown
today have a great day everyone we'll
see you tomorrow bye